so i have an uncompressed spring here
and this spring has a spring constant of
4 newtons per meter
then i take a 10 gram mass a 10 gram
ball and i put it at the top of the
spring and i push down to compress that
spring by 10 centimeters and so let's
call that scenario one right over there
where our mass is on top of this
compressed spring
and then let's say we let go and then
the spring launches this mass into the
air and then this mass is going to hit
some maximum height and let's call that
scenario two when we are hitting that
maximum height and my question to you is
what is that maximum height based on all
of the information that i have given you
here and i'll give you a hint
what we have to think about is the idea
that energy is conserved the total
energy in scenario one is going to be
equal to the total energy in scenario
two so pause this video and see if you
can figure out what that maximum height
is going to be
all right now let's work through this
together i told you that the total
energy is going to be conserved but
what's that total energy going to be
made up of well it's going to have some
potential energy
and it's going to have some kinetic
energy
and so another way to think about it is
our potential energy in scenario one
plus our kinetic energy in scenario one
needs to be equal to
our potential energy in scenario
two plus our kinetic energy
in
scenario two and there might be other
energies here you could think about heat
due to friction with the air but we're
not going to we're going to ignore those
to just simplify the problem we can
assume that this is happening in a
vacuum that might help us a little bit
so if we think about the potential
energies there's actually two types of
potential energies at play there's
gravitational potential energy and there
is elastic potential energy due to the
fact that this mass is sitting on a
compressed spring so our gravitational
potential energy is going to be our mass
times the strength of our gravitational
field times our height in position one
and our elastic potential energy is
going to be equal to
one-half
times our spring constant times how much
that spring is compressed squared
and so this is all of our potential
energy in scenario one right over here
and then we add our kinetic energy so
plus we have one half times our mass
times our velocity in scenario one
squared and so the sum of this is going
to be the sum of all of this in scenario
two and so that is going to be equal to
mass times g times height in scenario
two
plus
one half times our spring constant times
how much that spring is compressed in
scenario two squared
plus
one half
times our mass times our velocity in
scenario two squared
and just as a reminder what we have
right over here this is our potential
energy in scenario two and then our
kinetic energy is right over there now
this might look really hairy and
daunting but there's a lot of
simplification here
we can define our starting point right
over here h1 as being equal to zero
which will simplify this dramatically
because if h1 is 0 then this term right
over here 0. we also know that our
velocity is 0 in our starting scenario
so that would make our kinetic energy
zero so the left-hand side is really all
about our elastic potential energy so
it's going to be one half times our
spring constant times how much we have
compressed the spring in scenario one
squared and then on the right hand side
what's going on well in this scenario
our spring is no longer compressed so
our elastic potential energy is now zero
and what about our kinetic energy well
at maximum height right over here your
ball is actually stationary for an
instant for a moment it's right at that
moment where it is going from moving up
to starting to move down and so our
velocity is actually zero right over
here so v2 is actually zero just like v1
was zero so that's going to be zero and
so you have a scenario where our initial
elastic potential energy is going to be
equal to our scenario to gravitational
potential energy
and so we just need to solve for this
right over here that is going to be our
maximum height to do that we can divide
both sides by mg and we get h2
is equal to
one half
k
delta x 1 squared
all of that over
m g
and we know what all of these things are
and i'll write it out with the units
this is going to be equal to
one half times our spring constant which
is 4
newtons
per meter
now our change in x is 10 centimeters
but we have to be very careful we can't
just put a 10 centimeters here and then
square it we want the units to match up
so we're not dealing with centimeters
and grams we're dealing with meters and
kilograms so i want to convert this 10
centimeters to meters well that's going
to be 0.1 meters so i will write this as
times
0.1 that's how much the spring is
compressed that's our delta x in terms
of meters and so that is going to be
squared and then all of that over what
is our mass and once again we want to
express our mass in terms of kilograms
so our mass is zero
kilograms g
is
9.8 meters per second squared and when
you calculate it this is approximately
0.2 meters
and the units actually all do work out
because if you look at newtons as being
the same as kilogram
meters per second squared this kilograms
cancels with that kilograms right over
there
you can see that this per second squared
is going to cancel with that per second
squared right over there and then this
meter is going to cancel out with that
meter and so what you're left with is a
meter squared divided by meters which is
just going to leave you with meters just
like that and we're done we figured out
the maximum height using just our
knowledge of the conservation of energy
is approximately 0.2
meters